Mass layoffs
using someone's livelihood to balance
the books right it's so normal in
America today that we don't even
understand how broken and how damaging
it is not only to human beings but to
business and so we've literally created
cultures in which every single day
everybody comes to work and lies hides
and fakes
and we're asking our youngest generation
to work and succeed and find themselves
and build their confidence and overcome
their addiction to technology and build
strong relationships at work we're
asking to do this and these are the
environments we've created we have to
start by practicing empathy and relate
to what they may be going through and it
will profoundly change the decisions we
make it will profoundly change the way
we see the world